if the government laid a subpoena on us
to get your iMessages we can't provide
it it's encrypted and on the key and so
so it's sort of the the door is closed
but our business charlie is based on
selling these our business is not based
on having information about you
well you're not our product our product
is are these and this watch and Max and
so forth and so we run a very different
company we're just not making products
to sell you know that that's a very that
doesn't get me up in the morning I get
up in the morning and many other people
get up in the morning to change things I
mean that's that's who we are as a
company that hasn't changed that we'll
all we may change other things we may
become more open we may participate in
these things that we haven't done before
but what drives us are making great
products that enrich people's lives it's
the same thing that's drug driven Apple
forever I was at compact at a time where
the objective was to become a forty
billion dollar company well employees
don't get excited about that this isn't
something you wake up and you go I'm
gonna take the hill today to do before
and you know it's just not bad but
changing the world these are the things
that people work for and this pushes
people sometimes in the valley you can
all everybody can get so fixated on one
thing and lots of companies pop up in
and and do those things and and you're
not thinking enough about the next next
next thing and so it's it's something
that that we think about and I don't
know what the answer is I don't know if
the answer is we you know we always had
some ideas here and there okay
well I don't want to give you one else
we have people out there to copy us in
so I don't want to help them do that in
this country we've had to because Edward
Snowden and other incidents try to come
to grips with the idea of freedom
privacy and national security yeah
what where is that debate I think it's a
tough balance and I don't think that the
country or the government found the
right balance
I think they erred too much on the
collect everything side and I think that
the president and the administration is
is committed to kind of moving that
pendulum back however you don't want
it's probably not right to to not do
anything and so I think it's a careful
line to walk you want to make sure
you're protecting the American people
but you don't want to take there's no
reason to collect information on you or
but the or 99.99% of other people